militant nom masculin vient du latin me
laisse s'il une science soldats
aujourd'hui de militants est un brin
plus pacifique enfin la plupart du temps
le militant est celui qui soutient un
parti politique ses idées ses
représentants
c'est un réserviste quand l'adhérent est
lui un engagé rien
il s'implique n'est pas au point de
payer une cotisation ce pas folle la
guêpe il n'est pas non plus salarié
dudit parti le nid vite en s'auto
rémunère à la joie de mettre en action
la stratégie de campagne en ces temps
d'élections il fleurit à tous les coins
de rue armer de beaucoup de patience et
surtout d'un grand sourire il est passé
maître dans l'art de distribuer des
tracs et de coller des affiches mail
arme secrète du militant le domaine dans
lequel il excelle plus que tout c'est le
coup de sonnette pas de porte à porte et
de vous avez deux minutes
nine de ce nom sans militants convaincus
incollable sur les jours et heures de
marche et le militant et la toile
d'araignée d'une bonne campagne
électorale plus il ya de militants plus
le terrain quadrillé le militant a
malheureusement éphémère il ne survit
qu'en milieu hostile celui de la
campagne électorale après une élection
il retourne souvent dans son cocon
jusqu'à la prochaine bataille parfois
pas dire